in the mid 17th century England
experimented with republicanism this
experiment was the outcome of a clash of
ideas over the divine right of kings the
authority to tax and the separation of
powers and soon the separation of King
Charles's head from his body and after
this England spent over a decade without
a monarchy before restoring Charles's
son as King Charles II but given that
the country had been run without a king
for all of this time why did parliament
and the people feel the need to restore
the monarchy so throughout Charles the
First's Reign he and Parliament had a
difficult relationship Charles believed
that as God's chosen ruler of these
lands everyone who lived there had a
duty to shut up and do exactly as he
said all of the time many of those in
Parliament felt differently most of the
arguments that Charles had with
Parliament throughout his Reign were
over taxation specifically whether or
not the king had the authority to Levy
taxes alone but there were also
arguments over matters of religion
particularly over tolerance of Catholics
and how to approach the governance of
Ireland the king dismissed Parliament
several times over the course of his
Reign when he didn't get his way and
after Ireland rebelled some in
Parliament believed that Charles was
working with the Catholic Rebels there
to destroy Parliament and thus make
himself an absolute monarch in the same
way as Louis XII for 14 for France were
the king worried that his opponents were
plotting to oust him and so tried to
have them arrested he failed and so he
bravely fled London as a result
Parliament demanded limits on his power
he shockingly said no and so it was time
for war long story short Parliament 1
Charles was captured he incited
rebellion and was tried for treason the
King was found guilty and in 1649 he was
beheaded there was another War
Parliament won again and by 1653 England
was run by a lord protector Oliver
Cromwell at the head of a military
dictatorship but a mere seven years
later in spite of how much was done to
remove the monarchy it was back so why
well there were many reasons the first
was that Cromwell was the person who
kept it all together and after his death
his son became Lord protector and
Richard Cromwell unlike his father was
not well respected and many felt that
his weekend would lead to another civil
war which everybody wanted to avoid
furthermore the English Parliament was
fractured and so no business was getting
done and many just wanted to return to
stability the second reason was that
many of those in charge were Puritans
and they had a very strong sense of
moral righteousness and Crackdown on
activities they felt were immoral such
as drunkenness or most notably the
celebration of Christmas this wasn't
much fun for those who had to live under
the rules but may have disagreed with
them and so for those the restoration of
a leader who would leave them alone was
a positive the third reason was that
Charles Stewart made it clear that the
overwhelming majority of those who
fought against his father would be
forgiven and that those impositions of
power would retain their positions and
unlike his father he would govern as a
monarch Bound by the wishes of
parliament these things combined were Y
in 1660 Charles Stewart returned to
England from the Netherlands and both
sides agree to act as if the Civil War
and following regicide never happened
until some of the same problems cropped
up again a couple of decades later I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker call show wolf
Sky Chappelle katowitska Alex Schwinn
Adam Stalter rod D Martin AF Firefly
Jordan Longley Jerry lambdin why in
hockey Marcus arsner Spencer Lightfoot
Captain psydog Marvin Cassel Miss is it
kamun Yoon Winston caywood boogly Wiggly
the mcwhopper Aaron the white Gustav
Swan Maggie Paskowski Anthony Beckett
she went in spinning three plates
Coppertone Daniel tabian Charles the
first and words about books podcast